Ben, when we teased this episode in the
email about the Jensen episode that we
just released, the guesses that we were
getting from folks were amazing. I mean,
people were like, it's Charlie, it's
Warren, or it's Taylor Swift. And a lot
of people were right. Hey Taylor, you
know where to find us.
acquiredfm@gmail.com.
If you are looking to get more
publicity, we're open. Have Travis get
in touch.
All right. Let's do it.
Welcome to this episode of Acquired, the
podcast about great technology companies
and the stories and playbooks behind
them. I'm Ben Gilbert.
I'm David Rosenthal. And we are your
hosts. This episode is a very unique one
for David and I. Good friend of the
show, Andrew Marks, organized a little
dinner for us with Charlie Munger and a
few other folks at Charlie's home in Los
Angeles. You can hear Andrew a few times
in the background asking Charlie
questions. We are pretty sure that this
is the only podcast that Charlie has
ever done.
Charlie, aside from being one of the
most prolific investors of all time
alongside his partner Warren Buffett, is
99 years old. He will turn 100 on
January 1st. Of course, our conversation
was interesting because he's freaking
Charlie Munger, but also because it was
interesting to get the perspective of
someone who has seen the last 99 years
of human history. We talked with
Charlie, of course, about Costco, his
history investing in retailers over the
last 50 years. We also got to hear his
views on what it takes to build a great
partnership, what's gone wrong in the
global securities markets these days,
the concept of investing versus
gambling, and where investment
opportunities remain in the world today.
Yeah, Ben, this was such a special life
experience for you and me, and you and
me together to do this. And the fact
that we got to record it and now share
it with the world for posterity, just
icing on the cake, and the whole thing
was unbelievable. Yeah, listeners, we
knew we were going to have dinner. We
were not sure whether we were going to
be able to record it, and now we get to
share it with all of you.
With that, join the Slack. There is
awesome discussion of every episode and
the news of the day at
acquired.fm/slack.
If you sign up for Acquired emails, you
will get episode corrections and
follow-up from previous episodes, plus
hints at what the next episode will be.
That's acquired.fm/email.
And we have only one sponsor for this
interview. Yes, a special conversation
deserves a special sponsorship. And
long-time listeners will know there's
only one company in the Acquired
universe that is truly appropriate
because everything they do is modeled
after Charlie and Warren, and that's
Tiny. Yep. Tiny is the Berkshire
Hathaway of the internet. Literally,
they are such huge fans that they
started a company that makes bronze
busts of Buffett and Munger themselves,
but more on that in a minute. Yeah, so
Berkshire, as we know, started as a
textile mill in Massachusetts nearly 200
years ago. And almost 20 years ago, Tiny
founders Andrew Wilkinson and his
partner Chris took their version of an
internet textile mill, the premier
design agency Metalab, which designed
the UIs for Slack, Uber, Tinder,
Headspace, Coinbase, and others. And
they asked themselves, "What would
Charlie and Warren do if they were us?"
And that led to the realization that,
just like Berkshire discovered in the
physical world, the internet also has
wonderful niche businesses with great
cash flows. In fact, they tend to be
even better than the old days of See's
Candies and Blue Chip Stamps because
they require zero capital reinvestment,
have software margins, and can build
global brands much faster than the,
what, 50-some-odd years it took See's to
expand around the world. Yep. So, Andrew
and Chris took the extra cash flow from
Metalab and their other businesses and
created Tiny, the world's first and best
permanent holding company for wonderful
internet businesses, and boy, did it
work. Yeah, fast forward to today, and
thanks to Tiny's success, this
opportunity is no longer a secret. Many
people have caught on to the idea that
this can really work. But, just like
Berkshire itself, no one else has the
combination of experience, temperament,
access to capital, and frankly,
reputation that Andrew and Chris have
built over the past two decades. We're
investors in Tiny ourselves, alongside
Bill Ackman and Howard Marks. And just
like the two of them, Tiny is really the
long-term buyer of choice in their
niche. Anyone who's looking for a
permanent home for their profitable
internet business, or who needs a
capital partner for a co-founder or VC
cap table buyout, would be lucky to work
with Tiny. Yep. For instance, they just
bought the premier social network for
film buffs, Letterboxd, which has been
the founder's baby for 12 years and will
stay so within Tiny. And this really
reflects Tiny's whole ethos. Work with
only the best internet businesses,
commit to simple diligence, 30-day
deals, and leave the business alone,
either for you to operate or bring in
new long-term oriented management, up to
you. So, thanks to Tiny, this is the
only sponsor, as Ben said, that you'll
hear on this episode. And just like
Berkshire, it'll be here in perpetuity.
Tiny just became a public company
earlier this year, and they can now do
deals ranging anywhere from 1 million
all the way up to 250 million. So, if
you want to get in touch, just shoot
them a note at hi@tiny.com,
and just tell them that Ben and David
sent you. Oh, and one more thing, the
bronze Charlie busts, the perfect daily
reminder in your workspace to ask, "What
would Charlie do?" Just head on over to
berkshirenerds.store
to buy your own. And they also have
plenty of some guy named Warren, too.
Okay, now without further ado, this is
not investment advice. David and I may
have investments in the companies we
discuss, and this show is for
informational and entertainment purposes
only. And on to Charlie Munger.
Charlie, I was watching the NFL games
last weekend, and it seems like every
advertisement now is a sports betting
advertisement. Is this good for America?
No, of course not.
Are the dog tracks and race tracks of
America, are the casinos good for
America? Of course not.
They are just very popular. But that's
how Warren got his start, though, right,
at the racetrack?
Well, but Warren never gambled.
He only is a patron of it.
Warren wanted the odds in his favor, not
somebody else. Right. It's just so
simple. If you're Warren,
you want the house. You want to be the
house, not the punter.
Listeners, the next topic that came up
was retail stock trading and the idea
that for many Americans, this is akin to
gambling.
Well, that's the way it's organized.
They don't really know anything about
the companies or anything. They just
gamble on going up and down in price.
Mhm.
If I were running the world, I would
have a tax on short-term gains
with no offset for losses and anything.
And I would just drive this whole crowd
of people out of business.
What do you think about the algorithms,
like Renaissance and stuff like that?
Well, of course, Renaissance is probably
the first algorithm.
It was so simple. They sifted out all
the data for the past.
And what did they decide?
Up, up for two closing prices,
and down, down were more common than
down, up or up, down.
Once they realized that's the way it was
for various
reasons deep in the psychology of man,
is that man is a natural trend follower.
You trigger your gambling short-term.
And they do they just he just programmed
the computers to automatically,
you know, buy on one thing on the first
up day and
and sell before the end of the second
day. And he did it day after day after
day. And they did every day they would
the machine would, you know, the signal
for their agent
would say, "Your check today is
$8,500,000."
It's crazy.
tomorrow is $9,400,000."
Well, what happens is that the ones the
easiest trade is to front-run what, you
know, what the averages
what the index funds have to buy.
And you know what it is exactly. They
all know that.
And the way they get their returns year
after year
is taking the leverage, the midday
leverage of higher and higher and higher
and higher.
So, they're making smaller and smaller
profits on more and more volume, which
gives them this big peak leverage risk,
which I would not run myself.
And that's the only way they make these
big returns is to have this huge
leverage. It would make you crazy if you
were already rich.
I had the good fortune of speaking with
someone you know well, Richard Galanti,
at Costco and spending a few hours
lot about it. He's been there all his
life. It's crazy. I mean, it seems like
that's everyone on the executive team.
They've all been there their whole
lives.
I'm curious, how did you first come
across Costco or or Price Club at the
time?
Rod Hills, someone who saw Price.
And what he was doing, he said, "You
have to come down and meet him," he
said.
So, I drove down and look went through
his store and
talked with Sol.
And of course, Sol was a very
intelligent man. Sol wasn't ordinary
lawyer until he was 39 years of age. And
he was out of former government
employees discount company or whatever.
Was this in the Fedco days?
He was no longer with Fedco.
He um
He sold Fedco to the Germans. Uh,
Fedmart to the Yeah, Kmart. Kmart, yeah.
And did you get to invest in Price Club
before it merged with Costco? Yes, I
did.
But I just bought my stock in the
market. I wasn't I didn't get any favor
from
And so, how did you eventually meet Jim
Sinegal?
Well, Sinegal asked Warren to become a
director of
Costco.
He was looking for somebody with a
financial reputation. As an independent?
Yes, and Warren wouldn't do it. He said,
"Why don't you see if you can get
Charlie to do it?
I won't shorter plane rides to
directors' meetings and so on."
So, that's how that happened. And did
Berkshire ever try to become a
shareholder or acquire Costco?
No.
to get Warren to buy out the French
when they left Carefour. Ah. And
Warren wouldn't do it. Warren doesn't
like retailing.
Was it just that he doesn't like retail
or what was the big objection?
He's afraid of retail.
Practically everything that was once
mighty in retail is gone. Sears Roebuck
is gone. The big department stores are
gone, you know.
It's just too damn difficult as far as
he's concerned. And he had a bad
experience with diversified retail,
right? No, we made nothing but money at
diversified. We didn't exactly make it
in retailing, but we made a lot of
money.
Wow. And with diversified, most of the
money was not on the retailing
operation. You made a lot of that money
through
What happened was very simple.
We bought this little piss ant
department store chain in Baltimore.
Big mistake to compare it.
As the ink dried on the closing papers,
we realized we'd made a terrible
mistake.
So, we decided just to reverse it and
take the hits to
look foolish rather than go broke.
We just told Sy
get us out of this.
By that time, we'd already financed half
of it on covenant free debt and so
forth.
And they had all this extra cash
and our own stocks got down to selling
at an enormous
We just in the middle of one of those
recessions we just bought and bought and
bought and bought.
And all that money went back into those
stocks.
And of course, we tripled it just by
sitting on our ass.
And that led to Blue Chip
Yeah, yeah. It was part of the early
success of Blue Chip.
Wow.
And so, you know, you mentioned Warren
doesn't like retail.
else that people don't know about. Yeah.
We bought a little piss ant savings and
loan company
for maybe 20 million dollars.
And
when we left that thing, we had taken
out of our little 20 million dollar
investment
over 2 billion dollars
in marketable securities which went into
the rescue insurance companies as part
of their bedrock capital.
So, we we had some wonderful early
years.
And that's what everybody needs is
wonderful early years.
Wow.
So, in our Costco episode, we started
with the joke at one of the Berkshire
meetings probably 10 years ago. Warren
told the joke about you were on a plane
being hijacked and the hijackers gave
you one final request and you said you'd
like to give your speech on the virtues
of me kind of reminding you of me. Yeah,
yeah. And he said shoot me first.
We were hoping
could you give us your speech on the
virtues of Costco?
No, Warren was kidding me for being so
repetitive on the subject.
But
there aren't many times in a lifetime
when you know you're right and you know
you have one that's really going to work
wonderfully.
Maybe five, six times in a lifetime you
get a chance to do it. Hm. And
people do it two or three times early.
All go broke cuz they think it's easy.
It's fact, it's very hard and rare.
What was it about Costco that made you
realize this is one of those few moments
in a lifetime? Well,
they really did sell cheaper than
anybody else in America.
And they did it in big efficient stores.
And all the parking spaces were
10 ft wide instead of
8 ft 9 or whatever they normally are.
They they did a lot of right.
Yeah.
And they had a lot of parking spaces.
And they kept out of their stores all
these people didn't do big volumes, you
see.
And they gave special benefits to people
who did
come to the stores in the way of
reward points. The executive membership.
Yeah.
It all worked.
And that capital light business model, I
mean, when we were studying it, the
difference between
No, no, no. Price Club No investment in
inventory.
They make the suppliers wait until
they've been paid and then
they're scheduled to pay only
after they're scheduled to sell. They've
got 900 warehouses around the world full
of high quality merchandise, none of
which they have sitting on their books.
That's correct.
Yeah.
Our understanding is that Price Club
went public initially before the merger.
They just listed. They didn't raise any
capital. They didn't need any capital.
Who knows?
Sol kind of would like that. He was kind
of a financier.
Hm. He liked deals. He liked his
miscellaneous real estate like Yeah, but
it doesn't make sense. You don't want
You got an enterprise as big as Costco.
You don't want to screw around with your
parking lot to get other people
to clog up your
parking lot permanently and stuff that's
not going to pay you very much.
Right. You don't want them is the
answer.
Have you ever seen another business that
takes advantage of the virtue of the low
SKU count the way that Costco does?
Well, if you There are lots of them.
That little grocery store chain
here in Los Angeles,
Gelson's Brothers. Hm.
They wanted a high turnover and low
capital cost.
And they never made the least effort to
earn any money or have any They wanted
to share their parking lot with anybody.
Hm.
As you reflect back on, you know, one of
these few great companies in a lifetime
that you should bet big on, what advice
would you have for David and I as young
partners looking for a few of these in
our lifetime, things to look out for?
Well, when you find one, you you may
find it five years after you bought it,
you know. Hm. These things may work into
it or you may your own own understanding
may get better.
But when you know you have an edge,
you should bet heavily.
Hm. You know you're right.
And most people they don't they don't
teach that in business school.
It's insane.
Of course, you got to bet heavily on
your best bets.
And how do you develop that level of
conviction to know You work at it. You
really do a lot of reading and thinking
and visiting.
I'm curious to we wanted to ask you you
you've had this beautiful partnership
with Warren for half a century.
We're a decade into our partnership.
There was there was a lot of low hanging
fruit
in the early days of our operation.
You don't have any low hanging fruit
that is easy to recognize.
You mean an investment opportunity.
Yeah, that's right. But your
relationship with Warren, like
how have you
were all somewhat kind of similar. We
both wanted
to keep our family safe and
take good care of our investors and so
on.
We had similar attitudes. Yeah.
Did it change over the decades?
No, Warren still cares more about the
safety of his Berkshire shareholders
than he cares about anything else.
If we used a little bit more leverage
throughout,
we'd have three times as much now.
And it wouldn't have been that much more
risk, either.
And we just do We never wanted to give
them any least chance of us
screwing up our basic shareholder
position.
If you had used more leverage, do you
think there's some chance that
We would have done a little better,
sure.
Do you think there's some chance that it
wouldn't exist at all, that it would
have cost you the franchise?
No, I think it would have worked fine.
Hm. Does Warren think that? He's He
The situation lent itself to
if you were intelligent to just milk it
out.
When you leverage, I'm so curious on
after we did our It's automatically
leveraged. You go into a new store with
no capital.
Of course, it's leveraged.
Who wouldn't want a business with
with no inventories?
Right, that's a good point. By the
virtue of you owe a whole bunch of
people money on day one for these goods
that
Which is which turnovers are rapidly.
Right. It's interesting. I mean, that's
leverage. It's not debt leverage.
I mean, how do you think about debt?
Like after we did our Berkshire series A
lot of people don't know A lot of people
now do it
who
manage extra something.
They're just terribly strong.
And they're just forcing the suppliers
to carry all the inventory.
Isn't like we're the only ones to do it.
Back to the point on partnership. David
and I are coming up on 10 years as
partners in this podcast we do together.
Different than the investing business,
but a compounding one nonetheless. After
a 50 year partnership with Warren, what
advice would you have for us
interpersonally to make for a an
enduring partnership?
Well,
it helps if you like one another and
enjoy working together. We do. Yeah.
But
I don't think there's any one formula.
A lot of partnerships that work well for
a long time happen cuz one's good at one
thing and one's good at another.
And they just naturally divide it.
And each one likes what he's doing.
Now, in Costco's case, they had Jeff
Brotman who's very smart, but not a
retailer.
And Jim Sinegal, well, they divided it
up.
And they had originally agreed that
Brotman would be the chairman and CEO
cuz he was his idea. He founded the
whole thing.
But Sinegal said, "No, I have to be the
CEO."
So, there was a big unfortunate board
meeting and a big internal struggle.
And Brotman moved aside.
Was that after you joined the board?
No, before.
Do you think you and Warren not living
in the same city helped your partnership
last so long?
Well, it may have helped.
But Warren has very close relations with
all those people
that have
lunch every Saturday
at Berkshire headquarters. It isn't like
he doesn't have a
little coterie of people there who are
kind of fellows from the ground up.
Do you think it helps that when you do
spend the time together, it's special
rather than being common?
Well, of course we used to spend a lot
of time together when we were young cuz
we didn't have that much to do.
Now we've got more to do and then but
then it's just the other minutiae of
life.
So
it's different. Yeah.
It's funny. I feel like we have a lot to
do now but
Well, of course you do. It's really
difficult to invest money well.
And I think it's all but impossible to
do
time after time after time in venture
capital.
Yeah, we really wanted to ask you your
thoughts on venture capital.
get so hot and you have to decide so
quickly
that you're all just sort of gambling.
Do you think the role of venture capital
is being properly accomplished in
society? No, I think it's very poorly
done.
Charlie elaborated on this point with a
few things that we can't air but the
topic did turn to Bitcoin.
I've heard many comments you've made on
Bitcoin. I'm curious if you have a
thought on this particular angle. An
easy way to transfer money in between
countries especially when those
countries don't have a stable store of
value within that country. Is it good to
have an independent store of value that
is not pegged to a national currency?
for the world
as a whole to have a way of
having some currency.
The way that was solved is
for a long time the British pound was
the national currency of the
investment world. Then it shifted to the
dollar.
And it's still the dollar.
Yep. And people like China have these
enormous reserves of dollars.
You know, the money we make by
think of the
money people give us where we always
just print up these
pieces of paper.
Yep. And what about the common person in
some of these less fortunate countries
who don't have access to US dollars?
Oh,
they do it they are getting your money.
The dollar is very fungible. You can
always buy one in
anywhere.
I'm curious back to this point of
the role of venture capital in a
society. If you could design a perfect
system Well, I think it's a legitimate
business.
If you do it right.
If you want to give the right people the
power and
nurture them, help them.
And you know a lot about the tricks of
the game so you can help them
run their business yet not interfere
with them so much they hate you.
By and large, having
bumped into a lot of people in the
businesses
with venture capital financing,
I would say the ordinary rule is that
people in the business doing the work,
they more than not they hate the venture
capitalists.
They don't feel they're really their
partner trying to help them become They
they're only taking care of themselves
and so on and so on. And they don't like
them. How could it work differently?
Yeah, well, I I but that's not true in
Berkshire.
You see, our people way they know we're
not trying to discard them to the
highest bid.
See, if some investment banker offers us
20 times earnings or some
lousy business,
we don't sell.
Hm. If it's a problem business we've
never been able to fix,
we'll sell it but if they have a decent
business, we never sell anything.
And that gives us this reputation of
staying with things
which helps us.
And do you think that buy and hold not
only mentality but demonstration is the
key thing that aligns investors with
managers?
Well, it's rare, you see.
Everybody else has a standard way of
doing things.
The lawyers have their standard forms.
And everybody just has the same standard
form.
And they get the same standard results
subject to the vicissitudes of
investment life.
You don't want to make money by screwing
your investors.
And that's what a lot of venture
capitalists do. The world is full of
ex-GE, Goldman's ex-partners that formed
a private fund.
And they manage a billion dollars or
something like that.
And
they charge two points off the top plus
the split fee.
And that enables them to make very
handsome livings themselves
but the endowments are not getting a
good return.
And do you think it's specifically the
fee aspect of fund structures?
of the way it is. It's just the way it
works.
And of course
you really shouldn't be in the business
of charging extra
unless you really are going to achieve
very unusual results.
And of course it's more
easy to
pretend that you can get good results
than it is actually get them.
And so it attracts the wrong people.
People with investment capital turn of
mind.
And the people who make the most money
out of venture capital
are a lot like investment bankers
deciding which hot new area they're
going to get in.
They're not great investors or great at
anything.
What do you think
endowments and large pools of capital
should do then? Well, they're starting
to do it. The endowments have started to
say to the
all these people
that charge
three and 30 or whatever they charge,
they said,
"We'll pay your three and 30
but we're going to put in twice as much
money in the next half you'll get
nothing on it. We're just going to write
Perry passive on some of your
investments."
So the fees go down by 50%.
That'll take a lot of the fun out of it.
Fees down 50%.
And that's happening all over America.
They feel
had, misled,
irritated.
They've looked foolish to their own
trustees.
One of the issues I think in investing
right now, you mentioned it about
venture capital but I think it's true
everywhere. It's like there's just so
much capital and so much competition.
We're so far removed from the cigar butt
era.
We're in the opposite of the cigar butt
era these days.
Are there opportunities out there?
will find a few things.
But it gets harder and harder.
I would argue one of the easiest ones
was when
they decided a little group around Home
Depot they would copy the Costco model
in home improvements.
That was basically a good idea.
And think of the money they made doing
it.
Yeah.
Bernie Marcus. Yeah.
It was a direct copy of Costco.
Do you think there are more
opportunities to copy Costco?
There was another one at Costco.
Floor and Decor
is the current imitator.
And it's just this in vinyl wood
imitating vinyl flooring
that they're running a Costco model.
Huh.
And they keep adding miscellaneous stuff
to it, too.
It's the miscellaneous stuff that'll
eventually kill you, though.
Well,
it'll be simpler if it was all flooring.
Yeah, it's just like the vertical Home
Depot worked so well.
But it I don't know that it was totally
obvious. Like part of the appeal of
Costco was it was horizontal. It was
everything. Consumers could come, they
could make a trip, bring their big
wagon, bring their big truck.
Home Depot is the same.
They copied everything.
And famously Bernie Marcus came out to
visit Sol before he started. Yeah.
they came out they copied everything.
Sol was like happy to share the playbook
with everybody, right? How did Jim and
you feel about that?
Sol was a not a crazy he
he was
domineering and so on.
But he was also very intelligent.
Hm.
But there aren't many opportunities like
Home Depot and
Costco. There aren't very many.
Why do you think Walmart hasn't been
successful once they saw Costco in
competing?
They were too wedded by the ideas they
already had. That's everybody's trouble.
They just can't accept a new idea cuz
the play space is occupied by an old
idea.
They got in the habit of getting the
real estate for like giving it nothing
cuz they were in any little towns where
nothing was valuable.
So their always their occupancy costs
were like zero. And they knew how to
make big division stores.
That was their formula.
So it offended them to go against the
rich suburbs and have to pay up for the
good locations.
And Costco just specialized in the good
locations where the rich people lived.
And Walmart just let them do it year
after year. It was a terrible mistake.
Did you know Sam?
Walton?
No, never met him.
I knew the son, one of the sons.
And
they divided it up, you know, in about
six parts very early. Yeah, Walton
Enterprises.
So they had never paid much gift taxes
or anything.
The topic then turned to the auto makers
and the future of the car industry.
Look at how hard it would be
to go into the auto business and have
some big killing.
Who's going to win?
Who knows?
The whole thing's been thrown way up in
the air by all these electric cars.
All these big new capital requirements,
different ways of selling cars.
And plus they got these tough unions.
See, I just don't even look at auto
industry.
Do you think it's more investable today
than it was 50 years ago because of the
disruptive innovation of electric?
Well, for maybe for one or two
electric cars that are really good at
maybe.
But certainly nobody else.
So you think BYD is too
tough.
BYD was a miracle.
But that guy works 70 hours a week and
has a very high IQ. He can do things you
can't do. He can look at somebody else's
auto part and he can figure out how to
make the god damn thing.
You can't do that, you see. Charlie, you
invested in Hyundai.
Yes, but they're they're clever, too.
How was that investment for you?
I lost money.
Not much because I was stubborn. I held
out until it got back to almost where I
paid for it and then I sold it.
There's been a lot of discussion about
Berkshire's investments in the Japanese
trading houses. Well,
but that is a no-brainer.
Something like that
if you're as smart as Warren Buffett
maybe two three times a century
you get an idea like that. The interest
rates in Japan were half a percent per
year for 10 years.
And
these trading companies were really
entrenched old companies.
And they had all these cheap copper
mines and rubber plantations. And so you
could
borrow for 10 years
ahead
all the money and you could buy the
stocks and the stocks paid 5% dividends.
So you had a huge flow of cash
with no investment, no thought, no
anything.
How often do you do that?
You'll be lucky if you get one or two a
century. We could do that, nobody else
could.
It looked attractive at half a percent,
but you you couldn't get it.
But Berkshire with its credit could.
And the only way you could get it was to
be very patient and just pick away at
the little pieces at a time.
It took a forever to get $10 billion
invested.
But it was like having God just opening
a
chest and just pouring money into the
It's awfully easy money. It's
interesting that it's paradoxical. You
need Berkshire's credit, but at
Berkshire's scale, it's actually hard to
put enough money to work.
That's true, but why should it be hard
to make money?
Why should it be easy?
Japanese trading companies reminds me,
we studied another company recently,
Nike.
That is That's a very good company.
Yeah, did you ever look at it?
company.
Of course I've looked I've looked at it,
but I don't like style companies.
Mhm. Too fad driven?
Well,
I suppose if you had a Hermes and the
chairman of Berkshire bought it, but
short of that, I'm not going to buy any
style company. Ooh, that's a good pick.
To the style point, another one that
they covered was LVMH. What Arnault has
done has been amazing. So what do you
make of that company?
Well, if you're as good as they are and
what they've done, you have a lifetime
to do it in or without a lifetime really
three or four lifetimes to do it in. You
can create another, but it's not easy.
Hermes is on the eighth generation, I
think, now. The family running it.
It's not a bit easy.
They have meetings every day where they
make policy decisions and they choose
the locations one at a time and it's
work.
It's definitely work.
What do you think the durable value is
in these, as you say, style companies of
the very best one in the world, the
Hermes or the LVMH? What makes them
enduring?
Well, they just got a brand people trust
so much. Mhm.
It took them centuries to do it.
Our conversation then turned to
comparing Kirkland Signature as a brand
to Hermes.
Kirkland is a brand the way Tide is a
brand.
And
Hermes is a different kind of a brand.
Yeah, Ferrari doesn't make detergent.
No.
We've spent a lot of time studying these
brands.
How do you look at the value of a brand?
Well,
it's hard for us not to love brands.
Since we were lucky enough to buy the
See's Candy for $20 million.
That's our first acquisition.
And we found out fairly quickly
that
we could raise the price every year
by 10% and nobody cared.
We didn't make the volumes go up or
anything like that.
Just made the
profits go up.
So we've been raising the price by 10% a
year for
all these 40 years or so.
Wow. It's been a very satisfactory
company.
It didn't then require any new capital.
That's what was so good about it. Very
little new capital.
We had two big kitchens
and a bunch of retail stores when we
bought it.
And now it's got two big kitchens
and a bunch of retail stores.
Well,
Charlie See was a playboy.
And he his brother ran the company, his
older brother.
And dominated it completely.
But when he died, Charlie made his
brother his executor.
And now he needs a lot of money to pay
death taxes.
He doesn't have it.
And it's due, you know, eight months or
something later and
and so
they really wanted to sell so they could
pay the death taxes.
And See's was only making $4 million
pre-tax when we bought it.
And so that buying opportunity only came
about because the family needed
liquidity to pay death taxes.
We only found out about it because
Charlie See was on his cruise to Hawaii
or something
with this
guy who was a client of and doesn't
counsel who also worked for
Blue Chip Stamps who was the company
that bought it.
And
anyway, that's how we found out about
it.
We paid that guy a finder's fee even.
Who've never paid one cent. You always
say that so it was worth it.
Of course, but
you don't want to build a reputation for
paying finder's fees or everybody in the
world will be bothering you all day
long.
So what do you think so there are
categories like See's or like Hermes
where brands lead to pricing power? I
think your chances of buying one of them
is so
low, I wouldn't even look.
I don't even believe in looking at
things that I might find.
You're not going to get a chance to buy
a really good company. You're wasting
your time. Yeah, yeah. So why do you
think there are extremely well-known
brands in other categories, maybe
packaged food or something where Well,
there are a lot there are a lot of
original investors that buy nothing but
branded goods. And the one they usually
start with is Nestle.
And
it is filled rather They they've done
two or three points better than average.
But it's not a bonanza.
After that, our conversation turned to
Kraft Heinz and why Heinz is able to
have pricing power while Kraft is not.
It's very interesting.
There's something about the
flavor of ketchup on a god damn fried
potato.
It makes people really willing to change
brands over. They want Heinz.
And so we could raise the price of Heinz
pretty much.
Hey, but you try to raise the price of
Kraft cheese
and everybody goes in a rebellion.
Including the final final customer, the
housewife.
They don't care that much about whether
the cheese is Kraft or not.
Why do you think that is that some
Well, they want the sauce flavor.
It's happened elsewhere. In Korea, one
guy, some Chinese guy controls all the
sauces.
Every single major sauce, he controls
nothing at least 95% of. And it's
because sauces have such a particular
flavor that no one can imitate the trade
secret. Yeah. Huh. And that gives
pricing
get used to it and they like it. Is that
Coca-Cola as well? Yeah, sure.
Charlie, I'm curious
at age 99, what is something that you
believe today that 70-year-old Charlie
would have disagreed with?
I think I I I knew when I was 70 that it
was
Well, I got to have it. It is just so
hard. I know how hard it is now.
And all these people
who are getting this two and 20 or three
and 30 or whatever
they all talk as though it was easy and
they get to believing their own
And of course
it's not a bit easy.
It's very hard.
If you were back 30 or 40 years old
again today, would you decide to go into
the investment business again? Oh,
probably because it suits my nature.
But I didn't really enjoy
the
three and 30 business. Once I had enough
money of my own
I'd rather just operate with my own
money. That is a much better way of
doing it Mhm. than
Because of the
to deal with be forced to deal with
investment bankers. Be forced to deal
with
investment consultants. Be forced to
deal with venture capital.
The hell with Who needs Who wants to You
don't want to need other people.
The point of getting rich is so you
don't have to need other You don't have
to get along with other people.
Charlie, if you started with Warren
today and you're both 30 years old, do
you think you guys would build anything
close to what Berkshire is today?
The answer is no, we wouldn't.
We had
everybody that has unusually good result
almost everything has
three things.
They're very intelligent, they worked
very hard.
And they were very lucky.
It takes all three to get them on this
list of the silver successful.
How can you arrange to have two or three
answers of good luck? The answer is you
can start early and keep trying a long
time and maybe you'll get one or two.
If you were starting again today, do you
think insurance would still be the
vehicle? It depends on your temperament.
Insurance would be ideal for a certain
kind of a temperament. Mhm.
And
it takes a very patient person to get
rich in insurance.
It takes forever to get anything in it.
It takes forever to push everybody
aside.
It's very hard to make money.
I've heard you say as soon as you're
wealthy enough to self-insure you
should. Is there any insurance
it. I'm practically everything
thinkable. All the crumb bums of the
world that drink too much and file big
claims the insurance company where the
place
gets on fire or something.
Why would you want to pay that?
Your share of their stupidity.
Not to mention the overhead. Of course,
the insurance company needs to pay all
the people that work there.
Yeah, yeah. No, no, I I
It's crazy. Is there any insurance that
you carry today?
I carry no fire insurance anywhere.
Do you carry auto insurance?
Yeah, I have to. Well, you're legally
required
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know. Charlie could
No, I have to and I do.
I'm curious being that since these guys
are
very tech-focused, I'm curious not being
a tech person, how did you think about
the Apple investment and what gave you
the conviction to be so big?
What everybody has learned is that
everybody needs some significant
participation in the
12 companies that do better than
everybody else.
And
you need two or three of them at least.
if you have that mindset
Apple was a logical candidate to be
on the list here for which you're going
to select your companies.
And it's not very hard to come with the
idea that
it may be okay.
Making the list doesn't sound too hard.
In fact, there are these acronyms Fang
or Mama, you know, Microsoft, Apple,
Google, Facebook. But selecting the one
and putting hundreds of billions of
dollars into it We didn't put hundreds
of billions We put 10 billion into it.
To create hundreds of billions of value,
that to me sounds hard to pick the one.
How did you guys pick the one? We
couldn't find anything else.
Was it valuation or
Yeah, we got cheap. It got down to about
10 times earnings when we bought it.
2015, I believe, was the first.
Yeah.
It's fascinating to me this concept of
if you look at distressed debt or you
look at I think Warren in the last
Berkshire letter pointed out it's been a
handful of really good decisions or you
look at venture capital that's
classically power law distributed. Any
of these asset classes comes down to a
few really good decisions with high
conviction over an entire career. Yeah,
that's exactly what I It's exactly the
way it works.
It's not smoothed. There's no asset
class where you can repeatedly just do
there's the
The low-hanging fruit for the idiot is
it's not gone, but it's very small.
You mentioned this idea that when we're
talking about Apple, there's a few
companies that it's just really
important to be in. Do you think these
big tech companies being the winners
where all of the pensions and Berkshire
and university endowments and everyone's
401(k)s being concentrated in these
companies, do you think that was the
natural outcome?
Did we have to end up this way?
Yeah, it was natural.
That's why it happened. It was the
natural outcome.
What causes that?
Well, it's just it's just
that's what human nature and
competition, that's what it causes.
Will we eventually have one?
Eventually, this craziness in venture
capital when they're all all gone stupid
that's a natural outcome.
Will we have one 20 trillion dollar
companies and then the next biggest
company
the world's going to
I don't know where we're going to end up
eventually we did.
They just they just happened.
Would you continue investing in China?
What's your position with that? Well, my
position in China has been
that the Chinese
economy has better future prospects for
the next 20 years than almost any other
big economy.
That's number one.
Number two
the leading companies of China are
stronger and better
than practically any other
leading companies anywhere.
And they're available at a much cheaper
price.
So, naturally, I'm willing to have some
China risk in the Munger portfolio.
How much China risk? Well, that's not a
scientific subject.
But I don't mind whatever it is, 18% or
something. Whatever whatever is worked
out in the Munger family. So, it's okay
with me.
What about other geopolitical
considerations? Like would you hold TSMC
at this point?
Well, I don't like that as well as I
like something with a real consumer
brand of its own like Apple.
I'm curious what major companies that
haven't been mentioned do you think
people would do well to study the
virtues of like studying the virtues of
Costco?
Well, I only study two kinds of
companies.
One, I'm a big Ben Graham
follower.
If something is really cheap, even
though it's a crappy company, I'm I'm
I'm willing to consider buying it for a
while anyway.
And I do that occasionally.
And I've done it with great success a
time or two, but I'm like Groucho Marx,
I don't do it once or twice in my
lifetime for
big gains and that's it.
It's not like I'd If Apple was nothing,
you know, I've done it 100 times.
So, it isn't a bit easy.
Yeah, 100 times easy money is almost
non-existent.
One type of company is the cigar butt.
What's the other type of company?
The companies that people would do well
to
to study the virtues of Great brand
companies are of course are good.
Get them at the right price. The whole
trick is getting them on the few rare
occasions
when they're really cheap.
But buying Costco at its present price
it may work out all right, but that's
again, it's getting hard.
Yeah. Forgetting the prospects of the
stock, how do you think about the next
10 years for the business? I think it'll
do pretty well.
One more question for you in this area.
What is your favorite advice to give to
young people?
Well, I don't give advice to just any
young people. I give it to some. I pick
my spots.
I don't want to be more of a guru to the
young people than they already are.
It's getting hard out there.
And there's all this and
craziness.
Of course, it's going to be hard.
Where do the attractive opportunities
hang out anymore? It sounds like
everything in the whole world is
overpriced. Is Could that be possible?
Damn near. Of course, it could be
possible. It's not only possible, it's
likely and it's actually happened. How
did the world get so rich if we have all
this capital for so few opportunities?
It's the nature of things.
Look at biology produces a very advanced
creature like us.
We can sit around and talk intelligently
on all these subjects.
But it does it by killing everybody off
in brutal competition one with the other
for hundreds of thousands of years.
In other words, the system of nature
uses to get smart is kind of unpleasant
to the people who are losing.
So, over the last 100 years, we've
brutally shifted all this value from
labor to capital and now capital's all
competing to get into a very small set
of opportunities.
Well, capital never had Capital You
would It wasn't that it was all that
easy you you bought a long time It just
was a lot easier.
And if you continues to get harder, the
natural end is that you have Yes, an
unpleasant blowup of some kind.
And God knows what happens after the
unpleasant blowup with our modern
democracies.
You would get to be a lot like Europe,
which is quite dysfunctional.
Is it too pessimistic of a view to say
that the world seems to be out of good
ideas to match the amount of capital out
there looking for good ideas?
It was never easy.
If thoroughly understood, it was never
easy and it's harder now. Those are the
two I would
And you pay attention to how you're
handling the people you deal with.
You want a good reputation when you're
old and not a bad one.
And I don't think you're saying there no
opportunities whatsoever. I think No,
it's just low low expectations and
fewer bonanzas. Now, the beauty of it is
you only have to get rich once.
You don't have to climb this mountain
four times.
You just have to do it once. Well,
that's sort of your philosophy on both
sides is you got to be patient for the
great opportunities, but when they you
got to recognize them when they come and
and pounce.
We turned off the mics to have dinner
and then recorded a little bit more
later in the evening about Costco and
some life advice from Charlie.
So, one Costco question that I've been
wanting to ask you is all the puzzle
pieces of the low SKU count and the high
inventory turnover and there's just so
many things that fit together so
beautifully.
They're pretty obvious, though.
But how come no one else can pull it off
if they're so obvious?
takes a lot of good execution to do it.
You really have to set out to do it and
then do it with an assiduousness every
day, every week, every year for
40 years. It's not so damn easy.
So, you think the success is the magic
of the business model and culture? Yes
and yes, culture plus model. Yes,
absolutely. And very reliable
hard working
determined execution for 40 years.
I mean, they talk about the story of the
ketchup that
you could increase the price of ketchup
by 3% and nobody would notice.
But that would destroy everything if you
did that, right?
I would say the the central norm was
don't raise the margin.
Get it low and keep it there forever.
Which brings us to the hot dogs.
Is it true the story that when Craig
took over as CEO,
he did try to raise the price of the hot
dogs?
I don't know. I had no conversations
with him on that subject.
And Jim forbade him.
Well, I'm sure Jim would have forbidden
it.
Absolutely. There was no board-level
discussion of the hot dog.
No.
Those two would not have thought it was
a board matter to discuss the price of
hot dogs.
The one thing that fascinates me about
Costco is they seem to only be able to
grow 10% per year because they're not
capital constrained. No amount of money,
if they were to access it for free,
could help them.
it is. It's hard
to open too many stores a year.
New store, new manager, new this, new
politics, new it. It's hard.
Plus a lot of stuff has to be learned
and taught and put in place.
And so they didn't want to do more than
they could comfortably handle.
To start opening you mentioned China
earlier. Was it 12 No, 20 years that
Costco had the license to operate in
China?
Well, let me tell you what happened
there.
The first store
they tried to open in China,
the first store somebody wanted a
$30,000 bribe.
You know, Chinese culture.
And they just wouldn't pay it. And that
made such a bad impression on Jim
Sinegal, he wouldn't even talk to
anybody going into China for about 30
years thereafter. Ah. So what changed?
Why finally go in? Well, finally the
board started making enough noises
You started agitating. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah,
but who on the board could be excited
about the Chinese market?
Yeah. Who can Who knows?
Oh, that's so great.
One thing I found fascinating about
Costco was the fact that even though
they're at you know, the lowest possible
prices,
their audience skews wealthy. Was that
an accident that they figured out over
time or did they know that?
they they figured out to announce.
All the way back in the Price Club days?
Yes.
You always wanted the rich man trying to
save money.
Well, and it's not just that they're the
wealthiest customers, they're smart
wealthy customers. Yeah, they're picky
wealthy customers. On some topics that
are outside of Costco, you mentioned in
the Daily Journal annual meeting this
year that a young man knows the rules
and an old man knows the exceptions.
Yeah, it's an old saying of Peters. Oh,
is that Peter Kaufman? Yeah. What are
some of the exceptions that you've found
the most useful in life?
Well, take those goddamn Costco hot
dogs.
That's an exception. Anybody else want
to raise the price of hot dogs a long
time ago.
They just don't do it.
They just know that it's a
half famous
People bring their kids in to have hot
They they know they've got something
going there that's
worth extra money to them and they just
don't destroy it.
A thing that I've never fully
understood. I know you're a big fan of
the company BYD that of course makes the
the Chinese company that makes batteries
and electric vehicles.
I may be a big fan, but I'm sort of
hanging on by my hat while he lurches
around the track.
And they they make me nervous. It's so
aggressive.
Is that dangerous in a company? Well,
that's what makes me nervous. Of course
it's dangerous.
So do you think that companies should
try to grow at a lower rate than they're
capable of in order to be more durable?
Well, if it's Of course you do that if
it's safer and easier and so forth. But
I would argue that Costco where they've
done some of these things that are
extreme like the hot dog,
it's been a plus and they were it was
smart to not to change their ways
on one item or two.
And it seems like there's a spectrum
where on the one side there's Costco
that is just not a fast-growing company
cuz it's very difficult to. And on BYD
like you're saying, they grew like
crazy. I mean, you turned
this year has sold at least two and a
half million cars.
Most of them electric. That's unheard
of.
Well, I've never heard of them. They've
sold way more than Mercedes for
instance. More than Tesla, right?
Yeah, more than anybody. Yeah. Lots of
troubles and losses.
They ran into terrible trouble. They
They created all kind of They made lots
of mistakes.
They were lucky to be on the cutting
edge of this electric car business. It's
way more acceleration than most
vehicles. So you got a car with more
oomph than most vehicles. So the young
macho male
has a real
lively car.
There are a lot of things where where
electric car really works in some ways
that is better.
They're making a 90° turn.
You go right opposite a parallel park
you basically just move this way.
Turn the wheels 90° and go in. Yeah.
Well, nobody's ever done that.
If your car goes flat, you can run 100
miles on three other wheels or
something.
And do they have better economics cuz
they don't have nearly as many parts?
It's simpler.
Have you ever had an investment like
that before? I think you've invested
something like 270 million that's now
worth something like 8 billion in BYD.
Well,
very few people have a investment type
of
It's a venture capital type investment.
It happened to be a suddenly traded
public company when we bought it instead
of a venture capital type company.
It was a venture capital type play.
And they just went put the foot right to
the floorboard and played it hard.
Had they manufactured
way, both BYD and
and we
tried to talk him out of going into the
car business. They were going to buy a
bankrupt car business and go into the
car business.
I said, "That's a great idea for you and
all, but why would you want to do that?"
And
he paid no attention to us and went
right ahead.
Had you invested already when he told
you this plan?
And it worked fabulously well.
After huge mistakes that they were
almost went broke with their early
dealership building
system. Almost went broke.
What captivated you about BYD?
was a genius.
He was had a PhD in engineering and he
could look at somebody's part. He could
make that part, you know,
look at it in the morning and look at it
in the I've known he could make it.
I've never seen anybody like that.
He could do anything. He is a natural
engineer and a
get-it-done type
production executive.
And that's a big thing. That's a big lot
of talent to have in one place.
And it's very useful.
They've solved all these problems on
these
electric cars and the motors and the
acceleration and the
braking and the so on.
How would you compare him and BYD to
Elon and Tesla?
Well, he's a fanatic that knows how to
actually make things with his hands if
he has to.
He's closer to ground zero in other
words.
The guy at BYD is better at actually
making things than than Elon is.
Charlie, you turn 100,
which is an unbelievable statement, on
January 1st of next year.
Do you have any plans? I'm going to a
party.
Where's the party going to be?
The California Club.
But I've totally maxed out the room. I
can't squeeze another person
What captivates you these days? What's
fun?
Well, practically everything is.
Even politics, bad as it is, is kind of
interesting.
When you look back at your your and
Warren's time together, when did you
have the most fun?
We had about the same amount of fun all
the way through.
We're having fun now.
Is there a particular era that you
remember the most fondly that feels like
the good old days?
Well, I we remember we were sweating
blood in some of those good old days.
Oh, I mean, Salomon Brothers.
Salomon Brothers, Yeah. Yeah.
There were a lot of close misses.
We got out of a big problem at Salomon.
We could have had a big loss.
You could have had
more problems than just a loss with
Salomon, right?
Well, actually on on our when we
examined Berkshire Hathaway on our
podcast, our takeaway was that the whole
franchise was at risk during Salomon
Brothers, the entire Berkshire Hathaway
name and future. Would you agree with
that? Not so much. I think we would have
survived.
If you would let the whole investment in
Salomon go to zero, it would have
If If it all blown up and went to zero,
we would have written it off and gone on
and done pretty well.
What do you consider it to be your
finest hour?
Well,
we like to remember the close misses
where we were really getting into real
terrible problems.
We had a terrible problem with the
Buffalo News.
The Buffalo Evening News.
Yeah. Well,
yeah, it was There were two newspapers
in that town and we started a Sunday
edition and that started a holy war and
the other guy went broke.
Well, we could We could have had a lot
of bad publicity over that.
And you were you were both pretty young
and enterprising at that point. I mean
you weren't the Warren and Charlie of
No, but I was very aggressive about
wanting to
have a good Sunday edition.
I didn't want to own the paper for 50
years and no Sunday edition and the
other guy had one.
What made the newspaper business so
attractive at that point in history?
It was a gold mine.
That's attractive.
time, total gold mine. Well, and the
play in particular with the Buffalo
Evening News and the Sunday edition was
playing for the local monopoly, right?
To
Yeah, sure. Be the game the game in town
and with newspapers you could do that.
I mean, newspapers for decades had
EBITDA margins in the
50-60%
range, right?
No, only the little ones. Only the
little ones. Oh. Yeah, the big ones were
less.
30 or 40 or 25 or
I'm sorry. I I said EBITDA in your
presence. I apologize. Cash flow
margins. Actually, do you still feel as
uh that EBITDA is
a criminal the way that you've demonized
it in the past? Yeah, I do. I think I
think so. You got a big truck company
and
take the depreciation out of the trucks
out of the earnings, you're really lying
about the earnings.
I mean,
you witnessed its rise with Malone and
TCI and Liberty like
when EBITDA was invented as a concept,
right? Like what were you thinking?
Well, I've never liked John Malone's
extreme manipulations.
I don't want to be known as the great
manipulator like John Malone is.
He paid less income taxes than anybody.
He just pushed everything to the
driver's extreme. In many ways, EBITDA
was the community adjusted earnings of
its era. Are you familiar with the
community adjustment No,
WeWork.
Maybe um
final question to wrap up.
What are the set of companies that you
think are the greatest that you've ever
seen? Either that you've owned or that
you've not owned.
Well, there are a lot of great
companies.
Hermès is a great company.
In its heyday, General Motors was a
great company.
It just gradually went to hell one
contract at a time.
What do you think about the
predictability of
There were a number of companies back
when you started where you could have
said this business will be the same in
10 years. You think that number is the
same today or do you think it's much
harder today?
most places have a lot of change in
threat in their future.
Do you think most places had a lot of
change and threat in their future even
50 years ago and this story is
overblown?
There's a difference. Some of what I
call the specialized industrial company,
and Berkshire has a lot of them.
We have a lot of companies that are
quite insulated from really tough
competition.
Just because they've been so long and
they're so good at what they do and they
have a good reputation and high value
and so on and so forth.
What companies can you see today where
you can confidently say, Berkshire
aside, Costco aside, you can confidently
say the business will be
as good as it is today in 10 years?
Well, I think a lot of companies are
pretty good, but you can't confidently
say what's going to happen
because
you may get some guy like Iger in that
just wants to push everything and do the
right public relations and
so no matter how good the business is,
it'll be kind of phony.
Mhm.
Charlie, I have a personal question for
you. David has a 2-year-old and I'm
going to have my first child in a month.
What advice do you have for us about
building families?
Well, of course you got to get along
with everybody. You got to
help them through their tough times and
they help you and so forth. Yeah. But I
think it's not as hard as it looks.
I think half of the marriages in America
work pretty damn well.
And we would have worked just as well if
both of us had to marry somebody else,
by the way.
Well, you've said that the best way to
have a great spouse is to deserve one.
Yeah, sure. As long as both parties feel
that way, then it's a recipe for
success. Of course it is.
And
you got to have trust with your spouse
when it gets to things like education of
the children and so forth.
Yeah.
I love that. Well, Charlie, thank you.
Yeah. Thank you, Charlie.
Well, good luck to you guys.
Charlie, this has been a lot of people
are going to benefit a lot from hearing
this and your your wisdom and they're
going to learn so much. Well, you know,
if you start to think about it, it's
pretty hard. It doesn't look so damn
easy just to go out.
If you go to the ordinary person trying
to promote himself as an investment
advisor or some guy
he just thinks he knows everything about
everything and
how the Federal Reserve should be run
and so on.
We don't feel that way.
I will say with the people we get to
talk to who've built great things, every
single one of them says it was so hard.
It's so hard. You can't build something
great without it being so hard.
Charlie, thanks so much for doing this
with us. Glad to do it.
It'll be an interesting life you're
leading. You'll do pretty well at it,
but it's not going to be that damn easy.
David, total life experience and
complete boondoggle. I mean, I can't
believe we got to do this. I'm still
pinching myself. It's now a couple weeks
after it actually happened. I know, with
autograph copies of poor Charlie's
Almanac to prove it.
As if the podcast wasn't enough.
And actually, for those of you who
haven't listened back what, in 2021, so
2 years ago, we did a whole three-part
series just us covering the whole
history of Berkshire Hathaway. Part one
is on Warren, part two is on Charlie,
part three is on Berkshire and Ted and
Todd all the way up through to today. I
assume many of you have listened to
that, but there probably are a bunch of
folks who haven't. So, if you want
another 9 or 10 hours of Acquired
content on Berkshire, I really think
it's some of if not our best work. Go
check those out. With that, listeners, a
huge thank you to Tiny for being the
sole presenting sponsor of this episode.
If you have or you know of a wonderful
internet business, you should reach out.
hi@tiny.com and just tell them that Ben,
David, and Charlie sent you.
You can sign up for notifications of new
emails every time an episode drops and
we'll be including little tidbits as we
learn things after releasing episodes,
corrections, updates, things like that,
and teasing the next episode.
acquired.fm/email.
Listen to ACQ2. This is typically where
we talk about more up-and-coming
companies who are earlier in their
journeys or CEOs who are topic experts
in important areas like AI. Search ACQ2
in any podcast player. After you finish
this, join the Slack. acquired.fm/slack
and discuss with the whole Acquired
community. And if you want to get some
of that sweet Acquired merch that
everyone's talking about, go to
acquired.fm/store.
With that, listeners, we'll see you next
time. We'll see you next time. Who got
the truth?
Is it you? Is it you? Is it you? Who got
the truth now?